Hello and welcome to fire of learning.
So the first three videos we looked into viking in Norse history,
ups this settlement of Finland.
In the past video we tell the story from the Norse Sagas,
which I hope to help you gain an insight into perspective of these people.
And now we're in this video.
We're going to look at the Viking people themselves,
their beliefs,
their society,
their language,
their culture,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
So let's start out by talking a little bit about the science behind the great
forest.
At the Vikings were biking society was simply put divided into three social
classes.
The Yarl's,
the upperclass were marked by extensive wealth Lana's such things.
The middleclass to Karl's,
he's,
we're just the regular people who had worked various jobs and the various
things.
I just farming and blacksmithing and fishing and crafting on all that.
Below that was the thrall.
The thrall were essentially the slave class,
but there were various ways one could end up in this class.
He got taken from another land during a raid back to Scandinavia.
You all used to became that person.
Slave.
Other times if you owe someone money but did not have the resources to pay them
back,
you'd be held him in this way until you had appropriately paid them back.
Thieves who were caught stealing with sometimes become the slaves of the people
from whom they were stealing.
These classes weren't as rigid as other classes and other places in the world
such as the rest of Europe.
It was possible to move through them much easier.
You're all could become poor enough to become Carlos.
Carlos could get enough wealth to become a yarrow or they could end up as a
thrall and a thrill.
I could save and save up enough money to free him or herself.
The lower rigidity partially exists because in the early Viking age especially,
there wasn't a central leader of all the vikings.
Most tribes,
their villages or towns sort of operated independently of each other,
and this is very important because it shows that the Viking Raiders did not
operate as a single force either.
They were fragmented bands,
more like a thugs who really only sometime is coronate into larger efforts and
that made it much harder to negotiate with them or predict their behavior.
Back to the social classes,
Jaros often housed many of their followers and provided them with food and
supplies and such things.
They weren't just wealthy individuals.
They were very much authority figures of their respective societies in return
their followers,
both Carlson slaves but sometimes follow them into battle and importantly join
them on the viking raids.
The Vikings believe this social order to be ancient.
It's creation dating back according to them to the God.
Heimdall though is European feudalism spread.
In the Scandinavian Vikings,
society's became more centralized.
The classes did eventually become more rigid.
I was towards the end of the Viking age,
so the majority of the time while women has,
we'll see,
had more rights in north societies and the rest of Europe.
We're in the same class as their father or husband.
This social system with the vikings with a very different view of leaders and
kings.
It didn't see the URLs are kings as majestic figures of grand or they saw them
more like we would see a politician today or even more so a successful business
person,
someone who is intelligent,
obviously a very leader like cunning,
strong,
et cetera.
Basically someone who deserves their position.
Having this perspective,
the Viking has had little respect for the kings of the rest of Europe as a
famous tale.
In fact,
Danish Vikings and turned the court of King Charles and France.
The king demanded that they kissed his foot to recognize his grander vikings did
so by pulling the king out of his chair and holding up,
holding his leg up in the air to kiss it.
Adding to this,
as I've mentioned throughout the series of Vikings were more democratic than the
European counterparts.
The average person had a say in local affairs.
They voted on things and they were allowed to bear arms because the only writing
was done in ruins.
The vikings that a lot of things orally including maintain laws and government,
Norse people often gathered into meetings,
held that organized times called a ting or an English a thing.
We talked a little bit about this already to discuss local affairs and make
decisions on them.
Sometimes it was to introduce new laws at the time to things acted as courts
judging people for crimes and settling disputes.
Those found guilty of crimes might have been declared outlaws,
which was quite dangerous.
Title to hold in North Society being an outlaw meant that not only were you
deprive the receiving help from anyone but that anyone could kill you until your
outlet.
She was up.
Obviously these circumstances caused many declared outlaws to flee to a country
in many such outlaws like Erik,
the red contributed to the colonization of new lands disputes cause sometimes we
settled by what's called a home gong or a duel.
The two opponents would face off and battle and fight each other until either
first blood or in some cases death nor society,
as I said,
was a largely male dominated.
But women did have an interesting role in it.
They were expected socially to tend to domestic affairs such as raising the
kids,
maintain the livestock and gardens,
providing food,
et cetera.
But while their husbands were away on rating trips,
they took over all of the responsibilities of the household and women without
husbands to represent them.
We're allowed to speak and even votes at the teens.
Even though marriages were arranged at an early age,
women have the power to divorce their husbands and for a man's abuses.
Wife is seen as much more unacceptable and Viking society and the rest of Europe
at the time.
Some women even became wealthy landowners or even warriors alongside their
husbands.
Much of what we know about the Norris of this time from their perspective comes
to us from the Icelanders because it was in Iceland that much of the history and
such was first written down.
I remember that I mentioned that much of Viking society was conducted orally and
it wasn't until Christian missionaries went to Iceland that they taught the
Icelanders to write down their stories.
Then we may think these Icelandic people for taking the time to do stuff for
without them,
our understanding of the vikings would be much less developed.
Interestingly,
the Viking story that were written down and all Icelandic,
not in Latin,
which was not typical of Christians at the time.
Speaking of Viking languages,
the vikings from Greenland to Constantinople spoke a variety of dialects of the
language we now call old Norris or what they called back then,
the donk,
tuna or Dane tone.
Old Norse languages were inflected languages with three grammatical genders.
Language was written prior to Christianity.
You mainly in ruins though afterwards to develops Latin tie of alphabet.
All the Norris has a dramatic language,
much like German and English.
The languages of the Vikings would eventually evolve into Danish,
Swedish and Norwegian fairways,
Icelandic,
and even an influence in English.
Words we use today such as anger,
happiness,
law,
bug,
lake illness,
birth,
dirt,
a geyser guest.
He then haunt mistake,
outlaw race,
raise regret.
Rugged Rodan skills sprint Thursday.
They ugly wing are all words brought to us from the Vikings.
Here's an example of old north speech from someone else as I don't speak the
language myself.
Hold on.
Donald had it.
I mean
[inaudible] the off,
somebody's got to call it a little gun.
I'll bring the capacity.
That would be the [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] comment uptake means from that,
the upscaling
[inaudible], [inaudible] [inaudible] sport Tava and as mentors you mentioned
the modern Scandinavian languages.
Artists send them from this similar sounding language.
It was viking technology which allowed them to achieve such access in the
medieval age.
One of their greatest and most notable technological achievements is the Viking
ship Viking.
Long shifts are crafted from oak tree is,
and we're at times large enough to hold a hundred men who has not only the
shifts,
however,
but the vikings navigational abilities,
a facilitated their conquests.
How the vikings navigated is somewhat a mystery.
Obviously they had an extensive knowledge of nature using the sun and stars to
determine direction.
However,
these were unavailable when it was cloudy out of Vikings,
off he was landmarks.
However,
in the middle of the ocean,
this would,
this would have been hard to do.
They also used very likely the direction of the waves and the behavior of the
animals like birds and whales.
Their methods allow them to get to North America,
but they certainly were not perfect and many viking ships got lost and did not
return.
Ships were of great importance and Viking culture.
Obviously it was believes that people sail to the afterlife and many wealthy
individuals and Viking society were buried in their shifts along with their
treasures.
The vikings were typically always armed.
Even some women and children would carry knives.
Weapons included swords,
axes and spears with swords being used mostly by the wealthy do today,
difficulty to craft North's religion was also in a central park.
Their identity in lifestyle,
blacking religion known to us today as North and mythology and to them simply as
the traditions or the beliefs is very similar to the rest of dramatic paganism.
The religion was polytheistic believing in many gods and the cyclic believing
that the world simply ended and recreated itself.
Incidentally,
the North's believe that in the beginning there was only an empty void called
Dick and none could gap.
They're going doing again.
I've existed in between two separate rounds,
multiple Haim,
the realm of fire and niffle Haim,
the realm of ice.
Eventually these two opposite,
we're almost,
you're closer and closer to each other and upon colliding created the being Ian
here,
the giants,
the fire melted the ice and other gods and the north called the ice.
Here emerged from the eyes are the most popular known Norse gods or Odin,
a mysterious God of war and wisdom who wrote a six legged horse and often
interfered in the affairs of people leading many of vikings to claim to be
descended from him.
Thor,
the most popular north God was a warrior who protected the realm of the gods as
guard with his hammer,
which is father forwards in a star and lucky who was a trickster and a bit of an
annoyance to the other gods.
One day look,
he put a joke which led to the murder of Baldur,
brother of the blind God hudder and he was subsequently and present for life.
Norse mythology states though that Loki will bring about the end of time is when
he escapes from imprisonment,
the Gods of as guard led by owed,
and we'll go to war against the Loki leading the giants.
And in this battle,
the giant serpent fenrir will enter into the world and consume everything before
him,
including the sun.
The whole world will then freeze and slowly turn back into a void,
a void which existed in between the realm of fire and ice,
which in time would begin to slowly move back toward each other and recreate the
entire universe all again in death and Norse believe that they travel to an
afterlife and the ways in which people lived and were buried guide them on in to
the set for life,
such as the wealthy being varied in their shifts,
but also throws being varied in such a way as to prevent them from coming back
and haunting their masters.
The North had a high respect for their ancestors and believe that taking care of
the dead was necessary.
Often this involves a leading food and gifts and such at their graves.
Various afterlife existed in North [inaudible] mythologies such as [inaudible]
hell and Helga feel,
most famous of which is Valhalla,
where warriors been to be fair for riding a rock,
the name of the last great battle in which the world would end.
And so thus we see from all of this,
the vikings were not as simple,
murderous,
barbaric people.
They had a very complex society and culture,
and in some ways,
we're more developed and their European counterparts at the time.
In the next video,
we'll finish off this series by discussing how the Viking age eventually came to
an answer.
I say tend to continue with the series.
And for more videos like this and on many other subjects,
we should have talked about fire and learning and subscribes.
Thank you for watching.